[Music]  round three of the London chess classics  the last stop on the grand chess tour  after an exciting round to the players  came with their game faces on looking to  make a move up the leaderboard five-time  world champion Vishwanath on unknown has  always had trouble playing against the  wily American Hikaru Nakamura and after  a couple of bad moves at the critical  moment a non loss yet again allowing not  going to bounce back to try to give  chase for the overall Tour title all  eyes were on the new 2,800 Wesley soul  who promptly got in trouble against a  determined Levon Aronian but the tour  leader managed to put up a bulldog  defense and saved the draw to keep his  Lachlan first place the tournament is  heating up as the best players on the  planet looked to win one of the most  prestigious events of the year round  four action live from London coming up  next